like you know just sitting through one
episode of joe rogan really makes me
appreciate just how much [ __ ] a he knows
and b like how good he is at like
stretching out a single topic because
like no seriously because like after
like 800 something episodes four hours
at a time right like you have to
like i feel like when you're very you do
talk about current topics and you very
much
but as well like even if it's our
current topics he's very good at like
kind of like really extensively like
going into a topic to the point where
like you know a topic that can last
maybe what 10 minutes on trash tastes
can last up to an hour on the joe rogan
show people he's really stretching out
that uh 15 minutes
he's really thinking about his content
can we fit in here
no i mean you know when you're when
you're talking about politics you you
know they suddenly turn what could be
two minute conversations into ten hours
that is true yeah maybe we should
are you [ __ ] kidding me are you
kidding me like i think the reason
people come to watch first is to escape
political nonsense i i come to trash
taste to escape a lot of pleasures
i'm just like i just want to talk with
the boys
everyone who talks about it i feel like
is not i feel like no one is educated
enough about it and no yeah and so when
everyone talks about it i'm like i don't
know which level of education you need
in this topic but i feel that no one has
enough because everyone seems to always
have some [ __ ] argument that i'm like
what yeah the [ __ ] is going on right
like the prop the problem with like a
lot of political
trash topics
mug are you gonna drink water no drink
coffee out of it sorry i bet you're
interesting yeah i'll take the legs as
well give me the lid no because i
completely agree because a lot of the
times there are some topics where you
know you just genuinely don't know
you don't know which side to listen to
because both sides are just at each
other's throat and i'm just like i don't
i don't feel like it like every time
someone brings up some kind of political
like conversation because i a just don't
really care about politics in general
and b i'm again not knowledgeable
anymore you don't care about politics in
general that's taking a start in itself
joey yeah wow all right like that's
that's privilege
but like everything like it doesn't
matter what it is it could be like the
most far-left thing it could be the most
far-right thing and my only two like
answers is just oh that sucks or oh
that's good i guess i i keep up with it
but i do also really despise the era
we're in where like it's like all like
everything is political yeah no no
it's not that everything's political
it's like
everyone has to be involved in it and
has to be educated in it right
like everyone needs an opinion i feel
like the main players are all just like
youtubers and i'm like i don't trust
youtubers i'm a youtuber
i don't trust other youtubers i don't
trust myself
and i know for a fact that these people
cannot be that doing that good of a job
and when i listen to them i'm like okay
this is fine
you know to me it's like
it's also been highly monetized now yeah
like money has become such a big player
in it that i don't want to watch any of
these people on youtube tell me about
that that's true why they believe
ex-person has no rights or whatever yeah
because it's like you've got a horse in
in this race to talk about it yeah you
know you gotta you you've got to get
people angry and upset about it so you
can get dollars there's something in it
for you yeah yeah you know you know
which is why i also hate it a lot and i
also just don't really like talking
about it online because it's it's a [ __ ]
show and also it is certain opinions it
is a [ __ ] show and like i just feel like
some some things are just better
discussed in private with the person
because there's only there's only so
much you can say in our 140 characters
on twitter and that's
unfortunately where a lot of these
opinions are being spread and like that
it's easy to one misrepresent your own
ideas and two other people to
misrepresent your ideas and take it out
of context yeah and it's just it just
seems like a lose-lose situation for me
too i don't like i don't know
why it's just so bad or why don't more
people just don't just agree that
sometimes you just aren't educated
enough or you just don't know enough
about a topic to just have an opinion
yeah and you said and you say that and
like you know it's very i feel like
there's so many things now where we just
have so much information on topics where
yeah okay maybe someone can you some two
parties can present the same uh
the complete opposite uh argument but
there's enough information where they
can kind of both make their point
because they have enough points that
work with one person and enough points
that work with the other yeah it's like
okay well i can get educated on all of
it and then when you do try and educate
yourself on everything in a certain
situation you just you just realize i
just hate all of this yeah that
everything is just [ __ ] and nothing
works pretty much there's like the right
answer yeah
yeah yeah i i've gotten to that point a
lot of times where it's just like how do
i fix this problem i have absolutely no
[ __ ] clue i don't even know where to
start the more i read the more depressed
life and the rest of the world is like
first time
no one knows the answer and that's why
we're arguing yeah yeah the whole thing
with like the uh you should reduce your
uh energy uh usage to help combat global
warming and then it's just the whole
thing of but then also like bp is like
spilling the entire oil supply into like
the the ocean and it's like well i feel
like i'm like not really the problem i
feel like it's not really me yeah you
say that and people get angry and then
it's like well
and then you're like well change it we
should we should we should vote against
these companies but that's been proven
that that doesn't doesn't really [ __ ]
work half the time because clearly
someone makes a new rule that they can
go into the the
whole game is busted so no matter how
many times you change the rules it's
just not going to turn out to be the
game that you want to play it sucks it
sucks it all [ __ ] sucks it does and
that's why we don't talk about it on
trash
it always goes to the negative for me
which is why i'm just like i'm on trash
chase with the boys i just wanna i just
wanna shut off the internet for a while
i wanna talk about how i wanna be
reincarnated as a dog yeah yeah it's
okay to stop caring you know there's
just too much yeah there's way too much
because right now we're just so
overloaded with informations and things
to care about right i literally got to
like ship myself if somebody sneezed
within two feet of me and now i got to
worry about what's going on you know
in like multiple countries now i'm a uk
i live in japan
that's the biggest thing that's changed
right because before everyone could
everyone only needed to care about what
was around them right and now being
people on the internet i have to care
about every thing going on globally and
it gets to the point where there are so
many different cultures so many
different so many different points of
view so many different like experiences
that each individual has had that
sometimes it's impossible for a lot of
people to get the same
same like viewpoint on things because
even for us who've lived in like
multiple countries and have had like
experience with multiple cultures like
you can say we're cultured ourselves
it's like like well like like say saying
this in like the pure
unironic sense because you get this
sense whenever i go home
or whenever i hear about any of us going
home and you see people who have stayed
in their home towns and you see people
who have not left their hometowns and
they have the exact same viewpoint that
they got raised on right and you know
and
coming from the place you kind of you
kind of
you kind of understand how they got that
viewpoint even though you don't agree
with it you know what i mean but you
also understand that they don't have
anything to really change their
viewpoint in there because they've never
experienced it there's nothing there's
no like new information that comes in to
like stimulate that change in thought
process so forever they just think well
this is correct because this is what was
what it was like around me i don't know
about anything else that's happening in
the world so this is just how i'm going
to see the world but then you know like
for instance like i remember like when i
when i first came back to australia
after i was living here and you know i
would go see like my friends and stuff
like that who have been there like the
entire time like yeah i don't know like
things that i remember i used to be able
to like very heavily relate with and
like kind of almost agree upon i found
myself to be like oh is this is this how
i is this how i felt like is this really
what my thought process was like and
it's like and it's so weird because like
that didn't even happen in
that much of a large space of time like
that only maybe happened in like two
years yeah right i'm just living here
and i think you know like definitely
like doing youtube and stuff like that
has got me to interact with so many more
different
nationalities and you know yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah you know doing this job
like you're almost forced to be up to
date with everything that's happening
around the world because you have people
all over the world who are viewing you
right so yeah i have this weird pressure
of being like you know i don't want this
like one person from this one country
coming into like my streams or whatever
i'm being like do you know what's
happening in my country right now and me
going no i don't yeah yeah you get that
like what do you think about the current
gentrification of uh southeast uh macau
and
you're like you surely can't expect me
to have a horse in this race please come
on i'm just killing people from a cow i
know i know i'm a cow
but like that's the thing it's like you
know you're almost like pressured to be
up to date on that kind of stuff because
you don't want to leave any of your
viewers out and stuff like that and so
that causes you to just like
you know it absorbs so much information
about the world that when i go back to
my hometown and i meet people who aren't
up to date on that kind of stuff who
have completely different viewpoints of
the world because the amount of
information that they've absorbed about
the world is on a different level
it's it's i don't know it's like it's
it's a bit of a whiplash
i can't believe i used to think like
that that's kind of weird i don't even
know my own blood type so i don't even
expect people to like learn about like
the outside you know how do people like
me to keep up with like weird news in
some country i've never heard of i think
you should be the one to know your own
blood type i should i have a blood
disease as well
i have a blood disease
yeah you also had to do like a blood
test here yeah and you weren't showing
your blood type yeah having said that i
don't know my blood type either
i'm just as monkey brain as him
apparently
i know it's in the alphabet like it's
one of them it's one it's in the out one
of the it's one of the four
what is your blood type sigma
delta alpha sigma
[Music]
you know and i i do you know like you
said you do try to get yourself on some
things but there's just like so many you
know you can't be expected to keep up
with so many things like here's a
question then like do you feel like
there's a big difference between
explaining to someone that's you know
what kind of your perspective and
actually like
having the person really experience it
and empathize with you because i feel
like those are two different things yeah
i you know i i can i can sit here i
could go back to wales and explain
japanese culture all day yeah i just
won't understand it yeah exactly why
would you why would you do that why
would you bow at every single every
every word why would you say excuse me
every september yeah yeah
to me it's kind of like very similar to
let's say learning a language where you
can explain a language you can explain
grammar structures and you can explain
you know how how the writing system
stuff works but there's there's a
difference between understanding how a
language works and actually just
absorbing it and really getting a feel
for the language yourself yeah uh
i know there's a word for it um
acquisition language acquisition is just
you know this is just like learning how
it works on a logical sense and i feel
like i feel the exact same way when it
comes to cultures and perspective where
there's been so many times where someone
has told me about a perspective right
and you're logically like yeah i agree
with that you know you you know they
could be making the most sense but then
you kind of maybe move to the country
that they're living in or you go travel
there or you meet more people from that
same culture and you're like oh i think
i actually get what you're talking about
yeah you know like well yeah i think
it's like you know how you know you're
growing up and you hear about other
countries and you think oh it's that
funny little thing that country does you
know like i know i know like they would
probably do this about japan a lot they
would just show things like super they'd
like ah isn't that isn't that so strange
there's big men in diapers pushing each
other around it's like it's one of those
things isn't it but
i i think that when you get to
experience more cultures your mindset on
on when you see stuff like that changes
a lot like you go from thinking oh that
funny thing that weird strange thing to
think like i'm sure there's a story
behind it i'm sure there's a history
there's a place i definitely felt that
especially after i started dating aki
and you know through youtube meeting a
lot of like americans because like in
australia the image of america is not
that glamorous or like positive in any
way like you know i'm just saying it's
straight up like you know like i don't
think the image of americans with
america is a lot of americans are often
like the first people to bash them right
exactly i love you america yeah but like
you know it depends on where they're
from yeah it depends yeah but like after
you know actually going to america and
talking to americans and stuff like that
that completely flipped open and i
realized oh it's the problem was just
kind of my environment that was pushing
that agenda and the media that i
consumed that was kind of pushing this
sort of negative agenda about american
culture and stuff like that but then
when you actually go and you live it out
you see it firsthand and you see
everything else that they don't show and
you're like oh actually it's not as like
insane or wacky as like the tv shows or
the
[ __ ] my friends were talking about make
it out to be